abone ol
bu
Merhabalar
ben o zaman Harran
Sevgi aşkı bilmiyorsa Bir Gönül neye
yarar bir ömür diyoruz böyle başlayalım
Evet önce kitap Üsküdar Üniversitesi
teşekkür ediyoruz ulaşmak istediğiniz
değişen insan değişen bilimle ilgili
önce bir giriş yapalım ulaşmak 81
hayaliniz yoksa çalışmaktan asla zevk
alamazsınız engellere ya da
engellemelere rağmen
hedefe ulaşmak kesimde başarmaktır
runaan'ın her bir başarının çok büyük ve
özgün bir nesi vardır ikayesi var
başarmak amaca uygun sonuç almak
başarısızlar çok konuşmayı
başarılar ise sonuçları konuşturmayı
sever bu değişim kendini değiştirmiş ve
değişime adapte olmuş insanların meydana
getirdiği bir oluşumdur zaten Evet o
zaman daha Kim o zaman 1971'de oldu
sizden ve yaşta Belki biraz küçük biraz
büyük bir insan ve gördüğünüzde bir
fiziksel farkın var Onun haricinde Ozan
Baki 1992 yılı karar bu okulu mezunuyum
[Müzik]
1993 İstanbul Tuzla derken Foça komando
okulu subay Okulu dönem bir isim
jandarma subay Okulu ve ve Güneydoğu'da
iki yıl Ergeneli komando Bölük
Komutanlığı yaptım çok sayıda çatışmaya
girdim
yanımda 7 metre sonunda askerin şehit
olduğu mayına bastı patlamadı bu ve
2ekim
96 günü 11 ağustos 96'da işim evlendim
Ankara'da 19 Ağustos'ta Muğla'da göre
başladım ve iki gün Aynı bugünkü gibi 20
Mayıs 2022 her şey sıradan bir gün gibi
başlıyor değil mi insan hayatında ve
çoğumuzda sorsak ki pandemi sürecinde de
bunu yaşadık Biz çok sıkılıyoruz evlerde
niye eve hapsolduk ne olacak yemek yiyor
musun kafanı sokacak birim varmak Niye
sıkılıyorsun sen ben çok sıkılıyorum çok
mutsuzum
her şeyi sıradan bir gün gibi başlıyor
Ama bir anda
O sıradan bir gün sizin için değişimin
kaçınılmaz bir şekilde
oluşmasına neden oluyor Siz
istemesenizde siz istesenizde değişim
çoğu zaman Z çok uzak değil çok yakın ve
değişim ve seçenek nedir çok sorumluluk
mudur dersek Bu tamamen size kalmış ama
bana göre zorunluluktur burada şöyle bir
anekdot vereyim bilginin kendini ikiye
katlama Hızır 1930 yılına gelindiğinde
30'dan 60'a gelince 30 yılda ikiye
katlıyor bilgi 60'dan 70'e gelindiği
zaman bilgi kendini yedi yılda iki katlı
Dünya üzerinde ve şu anda Geldiğimiz
noktada bilgi kendini iki yılda bir
ikiye katladığını görüyoruz Yani bu
değişimin karşısında ya bu değişime
uyuyacaksın ki her şey değişiyor
değişmeyen tek şey var değişimin kendisi
Bu bazen şimdi söyleyeceğim
Bu bazen
bendeki gibi bir travmayla bitiren
jetiyle
kaçınılmaz bir şekilde oluyor bazen bir
kelimeyle bazen bir kitapla
bazen yaşadığınız bir olayla bazen bir
insanı seviyorsunuz insanla ya bildiğin
vesaire Beşer ama şöyle ya da böyle
değişimine Hiçbirimiz uzak değiliz bir
düşünce kadar yakınız Mevlana Ne diyor
İnsan bir düşünceden ibarettir Her şey
bir düşünce Evet kaza gecesi
2996 23.45 ne oldu bir görev dönüşümü ve
tayini çıktı 40 günlük evliyim
emniyet kemerini takmamışsın en büyük
hatam o arabayı bir başkası kullanıyor
ve
Rögar kapakları kapatılmamış Asfalt
dökülüyor ikaz işareti hiçbir şey yok
köpek Son anda fark ediyor Bir tahta
atıyoruz ben kendim komandoyum
ayaklarımı çekmeye çalışıyorum
çekemiyorum çekme var bir tespit bir
test terslik var Birincisi gidiyor
geliyor bileceğim gidiyor geliyor Biraz
bir bakmışım Beni burdan arkasında
atmışlar gecenin soğukluğu hissediyorum
bir bakıyorum hastanede 40 çok
kötülüyorlar Gözümü bir açıyorum baskı
yoksa devam etmesi İzmir ambulans
şoförünün sesini duyuyorum müthiş bir
hızlı arabanın gittiğini hissediyorum
Gözümü bir açıyorum Doktor ameliyat
diyor doktor elini tuttum hatırlıyorum
Doktor ne olursun beni kurtar diyorum
niye Allah'ım eşimi çok seviyorum ya
yeni evliyiz oluyor şimdi çok üzülecek
queo geceler işin tek hatırladığım şey
şu mozan hayatta kalmalısın Evet eşimi
çok seviyorum onun için tutmaya
çalışıyorum ve diyorum ki kendi kendime
gerçekten zihin çok güçlü Ozan hayatta
kalmalısınız neden Ozan ayakta
kalmalısın İnsan neden ayakta kalmalı
Çünkü oyunda kalmak hayatta kalmak çok
önemli oyunun içindeyken sonucu
değiştirecek en zayıf yerde bile olsanız
oyunla sakın çıkmayın arkadaşlar ne
yaşarsanız yaşayın çıkarsanız sadece
türbinden Ne yaparsınız şikayet bu
hayıflanma şansınız ol
Doktora sordum Gözümü bir açtım Ege
Üniversitesi'nde ameliyata girmişim
nasıl bir bakayım ben dedim Ozan exe
olmalıymış sın ölmeli misin dedi ama çok
büyük ters ipler olduğunu belden aşağı
çok ciddi kayıpların olduğunu
hissedebiliyorum içimden şunu diyorum
neden ölmedimki diyorum neden ayaktayım
gidiyorum Bunu kendime söylüyorum ama
doktor değil ki burada bir noktalı
virgül bakın hastanın başındaki monitör
Abdül sürece kalp attığı sürece dıt dıt
tavşan hızına göre Aynı hayat gibi bakın
Hayat gibi inişler çıkışlar hayatları
Zaten mutlu olduğumuz günlerde olacak
mutsuz olduğumuz günlerde olacak ne
Sürekli mutlu olabilirsiniz ne Sürekli
mutsuz olabilir ama kalp attığı sürece
nefes aldığımız sürece mücadele eden
kesinlikle
vazgeçmeniz gerekiyor
Bir Deli diyorlar bana 41 çıkma tam
böyle bel hizası ve hayatımın en kötü
gecesiydi içinde bulunduğu mu Çaresizlik
kaçınılmaz bir şekilde de zorunlu
değişimin yakıtı oluvermişti sınırlar
gökyüzünde değildir sınırlar zihindedir
arkadaşlar sayın izleyiciler her düşüşü
yenildiği travmayı zorluğu ya da acıyı
de işimiz için geleceğimiz için bir
fırsat olarak değerlendirmeliyiz ve ben
gözümü O büyük cihazların arasında
açtığımız zaman Üniversitesi'nde iki
seçeneğim bak lütfen buraya dikkat edin
bir ya Her şey bitti diyerek değişimden
korkmak ve hayattan vazgeçmektir ya da
yaşamakta mücadele eden kesinlikle ne
anlamaktır
vazgeçmemek li değişimi geleceğinizi
yine geleceğimizden yaratabilirsiniz
geçmişinizden
mi Evet geçmişten hatalardan ders almak
eyvallah Ama geçmişe takılıp kalırsak
geleceğimiz ne yapamayız geleceği kimse
bilmiyor ama geleceğimizi bugün
yaptıklarımız belirleyecek Bugün ben
geleceğimizi şekillendiriyoruz yaşam
bize her zamanki seçenek sürüyor bir ya
gelişme doğru ileri bir adım atmak ya da
güven değişmesi hissetmek için bir adım
geriye çıkmak hep hayat bize ne yaparsa
yapsın bendeki gibi nasıl sürprizler
ortaya koyarsa koysun hiçbir zaman
çaresiz değilsiniz Yeter ki vazgeçme
yine beni yarına ilişkin Hayal gücüm
sınırsız almaktaydı değişimin yakıtı bu
hayal gücünde Biz Leydim Evet karar
verme Şeklimiz hayatımızı değiştirecek
en önemli faktördür
başarı için değişimi yakalamak şarttır
Bende dört seçenek vardı bir hayattan
vazgeçeceksin için kabullenmeye cektim 3
da kabul edip eyleme dönüştürecek Team
ama otellerin solunu göremeyecek Team
tren ortasında kalacaktır yine baz
geçecektim son her şeyini Tüm benliğinle
ruhunla ha ortaya koyarak her şeyini
vazgeçmeden mücadele demeyecektim ki
vazgeçmemek et yapabilmenin değişimin
büyük bir sorun oluşturmaktadır değişim
normal bir olaydır var oluşun içinde o
tavsiye olarak vardır Bizim için
hayatımızda getirin önemli bir şey varsa
asla ama asla ondan vazgeçmeyiz en
değerlileri mi kaybetmiştim içimdeki
karanlık acaba iyileşir miydi bipsiz
karanlık kuyularda gibiydim gecenin
matemi ruhumu böyle çöküyordu üç ay
uykuları haram olmuştu oradaki duvarlar
bana böyle bir yalnızlık gibi beynime
saklanıyordu Sanki bir gün kafaya
gittikleri gönder sesinden sonra bir
profesör fizik tedavi uzmanı Doktor bana
makineli tüfek gibi hızı su soruyu sordu
da bunları söyledin bu hayattan Ne
bekliyorsunuz üç dört kere çocuğun
mesleğinin eşime döndüm Şimdi dedi
yanında dedi teker gider Yarını Unut Be
yürümeyi dedim onu dedim buraya
döneceğiz Evet artık yeni bir mücadele
ya da heyecana dayanamam katlanamam
yaşamaya ve bunların hiçbirine gerek yok
dediğiniz yaz belki de değişimin
başlangıcı hayatımızın dönüm ve Kırılma
Noktası da benim 2ekim 96'da hem benim
kırıldı hem de hayatımın gerçekten çok
büyük bir dönüm ve kırılma noktasıydı
iki kere birlikte yaşadım hep sevdiği
ölçüde bilebilir sevdiğiniz ölçüde
başarabilirsiniz yaşamak mutlu olmak
başarmak için vazgeçmeden sevmek ve
değişmez şak değişim bendeki gibi
zorunlu kaçırılmaz bazen bir tır ama
bazı bir kayıt olabiliyor bazen zorunlu
olmayan bazen içsel bazen dışsal Ama ne
olursa olsun değişim için vazgeçmeden
kesinlikle harekete geç Ne gerekiyorsa
bunu söylemiştim geçiyorum Evet şartlar
öyle bir hal alıyor hali yok ki değişim
kaçınılmaz olur yaşadığı trajedi bizi
zorluk lan tamamen farklı bir hale
getirebiliyor ve yaşam Tiyatrosu da
farklı bir rol görebiliyor Ben yeni
rolüne adapte olup mutlu olacaksın onu
çok iyi bir şekilde oynayacaktım ya da o
rolünü oynamayı pve mutsuz olacaktır
değişimden kaçacaksın karar ve tercih
tamamen bana ait tamamen size ait
değişimden değişimi dışında kalarak
kesinlikle kurtulamayız Arkadaşlar her
gün yeni bir gün her sabah dünyadaki her
şeyin tazelendi ve değişti yeni bir
Sabahtır her engel hayat koşulları
iyileştirecek ve değişimi başlatacak
önemli birinin ihtiyaçtır gereklilikler
ve değişim ihtiyacı zihnimizde bir
bulldozer gibi yol açmalıdır bir
değişime karşı direnç göstermek zamanın
ruhuna yenik düşmek mutsuz olmak ve
sonuçta kaybetmek demektir Ben geç bu
kayıtlarını değiştiremez dim ne iş Ne
değiştirebilir dim düşüncemi tavırları
mı Her sabah hayatı uyandığım zaman ne
yapabileceğimi erişim koşulları Evet
değiştirebilirim ya su davrandığında
davrandığınızda alacağınız yaralar size
ileride cesaretimizin madalyalı olarak
geri gelecektir ilk engel de ilk düşmede
kesinlikle Pes etmeyin kesimde
vazgeçmeyin nihai Zafer aradaki tüm
yenilgileri ne yapar kapatır o yüzden
söylemek ve düşünmek arkadaşlar yapmak
arasında inanın çok büyük bir fark var
değişim için kendini yenmeli ve içindeki
Savaşı başlatmadım değişim açısından
düşünmek düşünceyi düzeltmek zihin
hapishanesinden kurtulmak çok önemli
çünküm
Ezine o kadar güçlü ki ya Yapabileceğin
aşağı inanacaksın ve tüm gücünle o yolda
devam edeceksin Gaga her türlü yeniliği
daha başla kapatıp ve dış dünya ve
değişme karşıt kapatacaksın ki o anlamda
insan beynim ki beni bu vücudu üzerinde
taşıyorsunuz heryeri her nereye
giderseniz odasını zaten ona benden
Düşüncenin gücü şey yok edebilir var
edebilir Vücudun nasıl gibi bağışıklık
sistemi varsa evinin bağışıklık sistemi
de düşünce güçlüdür ve düşünceyi
düzeltmesi dir hep soğuk Hedef koymalı
ydın hedef koyan hareket eden kazanır
bekleyen yerinde Duran kaybeden kazanla
birlikte kimliğini kaybetmiştim Ben
kimdim hayattan ne istiyorum hayatımı
benim için anlamı neydi bu dünyada pil
olun bölüm neydi ruhum bunları
başarabilmek için bana yok gösterecek
miydi varsa neydi inandığım şey neydi
ilk bir yıl bunun 45 günü sadece yatağa
bağlı yaptım İlk bir laf Sana da kaldım
sonraki bir yıl Muğla'da evde kaldım
sadece fizik tedavisi okumadığım Kitap
okudum derken 98 yılında yüksekten savaş
Evet mm yılında çok yüksek bir nokta
bitirdim mm yılında doktoraya başladım
2002 yılında silahlı kuvvetlerden
yüzbaşı olarak Emekli oldum üç aylık bir
elektrik süresinden sonra araştırma
göster işe başladım 25 yılında Doktor
oldum 2006 yılı yardımcı Uçan 2007 yılı
Doçent v2013 yılında Profesör oldu moda
akademik kariyere başlamakla birlikte
tamamen değişmişti artık ben yeni bir
insandım hayat Evet zorluklara ve
güçlüklere rağmen çok güzel ve
hedefinize neden ulaşmak istediğiniz e
engellere kayıtları değil Yapmak yapmak
istedikleriniz odaklanmalı sınız değişim
hepimiz için belirsize korkutucu
olabilir bunun gelmenin yolu kendimizi
sakin olmayan bir durumun İçine sokmak
ve Konfor alanının dışına çıkmak hepimiz
için mutluluk İyi olmak için çok ama çok
neden var sevgili arkadaşlar sahip
olduklarımla Neler yapabileceğimi karar
verdim ve sahaya indim savaştım ol bu
fark edip onları önerdim ayağımı
çalışmamasına Bergama aşağıdaki
kayıtları odaklan Saydım Bugün şu anda
bu konuşmayı sizi ne yapıyor
olmayacaktır değişim pek çok Ruha iyi
gelen bir şifadır arkadaşlar engelleri
çalışarak üreterek severek değişime gel
hayatıma ve fiziksel pozisyonuna
adapte olarak aşmayı öğrendim Evet 2014
yılında tuzu fakültesinde dekan olarak
görevlendirildim ve Türkiye Cumhuriyeti
tarihinin eğitim Akademi alanında
Tekerlekli sandalye kullanan Cumhuriyet
tarihinin ilk Bakanı sıfatıyla Sayın
cumhurbaşkanından Akademi alanında
engelleri aş anlar ödülünü aldım her
engelin Her sıkıntının altında bir
hazine var bize düşen görev bu
sıkıntının altındaki hazine yine yapmak
görebilmek arkadaşlar Evet mutluluk
başarı değişim kısaca yaşama sırrı nedir
sevmektir sevgi her zaman iz bırakır
yapamayacakları mıza
değiştiremeyeceklerimi Z kontrolü bu
etkileri değil yapabileceklerinize
kontrol edebileceklerini odaklanmalıyız
hayatımızda başımıza gelen her durumu
kontrol edemeyeceğiniz de kesinlikle
Bilmemiz gerekiyor yaşamaktan sevmekten
hiçbir zaman vazgeçmedim en önemli gücüm
karşılaştım olaylar karşısındaki tutumun
aklımı irademi kullanışı ve değişme çok
hızlı bir şekilde adet olmadı Ne olur
her sesinde mm personel var Aç
indeksinde 17 sıradayım Türkiye'de
yaklaşık 191 akademik personel var
2663 sıradayım bir hayat iki ayrı
kariyere zihin açılınca değişim
kendiliğinden başlıyor sırada almış gibi
zannedilen bir anın bir anın bile
farkına vararak farklı parça ederek
mandalı güzel nefes almanı ne kadar
önemli bir şey olduğunu gösterdi Belki
de özgürleşme nizi sağlayacak değişim
yeni bir heyecan veya yeni bir oluşum da
bizi hayatta ne bekliyorduk şu anda
bekliyorduk çocuğumuz var mı var eşim
beraber Benimle hala çok şu ana kadar
beraber mesleğim Evet şu anda akademik
yazar akademisyen yazar Ozan bak
Profesör Doktor ve devam ediyor askerlik
yapıyorum şu anda devrediyorum tüm kenar
tuğlalar ve taraftan Çok şey bekliyoruz
arkadaşlar Neden iyi bir aileye sahip
Sen dünyanın en mutlu kişi ve başarılı
kişi sensin demektir neye inanıyorsanız
onu elde edersiniz her şeyi
değiştirebilecek olan küçücük ufacık
şeylerdir günlük yapılabilecek basit ama
istikrarlı iyileştirme yan yana içecek
küçücük şeyler küçük ufak şeyleri büyük
ve büyük bir aşkla yapmaktır Aslolan
sevmekten aşktan mücadele eden
değişimden hayata Meydan okumaktan asla
vazgeçmedim kaybettiğinde değil
vazgeçtiğinde her şey biter Vazgeçme
bırakma noktası çok önemli bir eşittir o
işi yapmayanlar 13 Adele bırakmayanlar
ve vaz mı vazgeçmeyenler Her o kazanır
Hayat vazgeçenleri değil her zaman için
azmedenleri hatırlar torunlarınız
anlatacak bir öyküyüz olsun arkadaşlar
acılar zorluklar sıkıntılar ziraatla
Kırklar karşında res etmeyen koşa
yürekleri değişimden korkmayın
mücadeleyi vazgeçmeden sürdürebilme
cesareti gösteren O yüce gönüllere selam
olsun Yarın hayatınızın son günü olsaydı
bugün geçirdiğiniz gibi mi geçirirsiniz
hayatınız yarın sona erecek olsaydı Neyi
yapmadığınız için Pişmanlık duyarsınız
değişimin sana özünden getirdiği
potansiyeli kendisini anlama ve tanıma
gücü ve fırsatı sunmaktadır bir hayat
hayat yaşamaktan ibarettir ve yaşayan
herkes değişmem hazırlıklı olmalıdır
beni sabırla dinlediğiniz için teşekkür
ederim
com